all right this is very serious stuff the
Donald Trump rape trial is underway in
New York and it is not getting nearly
the attention that it likely deserves
we're going to go over a few of the
headlines a few of the articles but this
this is very serious stuff and very
graphic stuff is happening in this trial
uh the guardian has an article Donald
Trump raped me writer E Gene Carroll
testifies in New York Court this is now
under oath in court
advice columnist says former president
quote shattered my reputation and says
alleged attack left her unable to enjoy
romantic life Carol testified in her
civil lawsuit seeking damages for
battery after Trump allegedly sexually
assaulted her in a New York Department
Store changing room in 1996 and for
defamation after he accused her of lying
and perpetrating a hoax when she went
public with her accusations in a book
quote under oath to the jury from E Gene
Carroll and there are no cameras in the
courtroom so while we have are these
reports quote I'm here because Donald
Trump raped me and when I wrote about it
he said it didn't happen he lied and
shattered my reputation I'm here to try
and get my life back
before Carol testified judge Lewis
Kaplan warned Trump may have crossed the
line into jury tampering after the
former president posted an attack on a
social media site truth social calling
Carol's accusations a made-up scam and a
Witch Hunt we're going to look at those
posts in a moment a Politico article
also explains uh the details of the
alleged event Carol a magazine columnist
has accused Trump of sexually assaulting
her in a dressing room of luxury
department store Bergdorf Goodman in the
mid 90s
and then indeed there is a yahoo news
article
from Yahoo News Canada
which goes into the graphic detail that
e Gene Carroll revealed
under oath talking about the sixth floor
lingerie department
a lacy bodysuit that Trump jokingly
suggested she try on
um
and it includes all sorts of graphic
details that I don't know that I
necessarily need to go into but they are
they are quite violent now Donald
Trump's reaction to this he went on
Truth social
and he posted the following these are
the posts that could be considered
tampering quote the E Gene Carroll case
Ms Bergdorf Goodman is a made-up scam
her lawyer is a political operative
financed by a big political donor that
they said didn't exist only to get
caught lying about that just look at her
CNN interview before and after the
commercial break like a different person
she said there was a dress using the old
Monica Lewinsky stuff then she didn't
want to produce it the dress should be
allowed to be part of the case this is a
fraudulent and false story Witch Hunt
then continuing in a second post to
Troth quote they got caught lying the
Miss Berg going from Ms to miss Bergdorf
Goodman case is financed by a big
political donor that they tried to hide
does anybody believe that I would take a
then almost 60 year old woman that I
didn't know from the front door of a
very crowded department store with me
being very well known to put it mildly
into a tiny dressing room and her she
didn't scream there are no Witnesses
nobody saw this she never made a police
complaint if I was seen there with a
woman big press scam now
aside from the facts of this case which
are slowly uh being asserted in court
this is not even close to the only
sexual assault allegation against Donald
Trump not by a long shot we're talking
about dozens of such allegations
including from one of Donald Trump's own
Ex-Wives now we could mention many of
them but one particular allegation of
note
relates to a lawsuit filed in 2016 by a
woman under the name Jane Doe against
Donald Trump which accused Trump of
raping her when she was 13 years old
in 1994 this lawsuit which I've
mentioned to you before was filed in New
York it was dismissed in 2017 by a judge
who said the allegations aren't specific
enough and the accuser later withdrew
the lawsuit reportedly because of the
threats to her and her family's safety
Trump of course has repeatedly denied
those allegations and has said that they
are quote false and ridiculous so where
is the E Gene Carroll case going
remember there are two parts to this
there's the defamation allegation
against Trump there is also the actual
assault allegation which can be brought
despite traditional statutes of
limitations because of a particular New
York law that says if you didn't we
which opens up a window for filing such
cases
even if the statute of limitations has
expired if you didn't previously bring
the allegation forward I have no idea in
the world what is going to happen with
this case there were questions about
whether Trump would even be in the
courtroom so far he has not been he has
an event in New Hampshire later today
which we will cover live which certainly
puts him closer to New York than Florida
does but at this point no indication
that he plans to be there